[Applause]
[Music]
if I talked about a European island
that's divided into a former British
colony where you drive on the left and
whose economy has grown substantially in
recent years what country or do you
think about I'm sure many of you would
say Ireland right sorry we won't be
looking at the country of Guinness the
Hollings and green leprechauns this time
there's another Ireland's which isn't
talked about much that also fits that
description in this video we're going to
talk about Cyprus Mediterranean island's
that is much hotter than Ireland's but
which is also a territory split in two
[Music]
you see this story isn't that well known
on the island of Cyprus we can find two
different states the Republic of Cyprus
and the self-proclaimed Turkish Republic
of Northern Cyprus which is only
recognized as a sovereign country by
Turkey so while the southern part is
fully integrated within the European
Union the northern part only interacts
with turkeys political and commercial
networks so as you can imagine both
sides have huge political and economic
differences
now surely many of you might be
wondering well but how did this small
Mediterranean island's become divided
what is the Turkish Republic of Northern
Cyprus we're to answer these and many
other questions in this video
[Music]
cypress a casualty of the great empires
this isn't a unique case in many of the
colonies of the former British Empire D
colonialization brought a lot of ethnic
and territorial problems this is just
another example Cyprus was granted to
the United Kingdom as a protectorate
following an agreements with the Ottoman
Empire at the end of the 19th century it
was given control of the islands in
gratitude for the support that the
British had given to the Ottomans in
their war against Russia however it
wasn't until the beginning of world war
1 in 1914 that the United Kingdom
formally declared Cyprus a colony now
how was this colonial territory how did
it end how did it affect Cypriot history
well the truth is that the colonization
of Cyprus wasn't plain sailing
you see many Cypriots especially those
of Greek ethnicity utterly rejected
colonial rule and now that they had been
freed from the Ottoman Empire they
wanted to annex the island to Greece
something known as a gnosis
and as you can imagine the Cypriots of
Turkish origin didn't like that idea
very much as they didn't identify with
Greece at all we're talking about a
confrontation that fueled several
revolts which in some cases had to be
stifled by British forces now the
biggest problem the final confrontation
happens after they gained independence
in 1960
[Music]
the confrontation for power between the
Greek community and the Turkish
community escalated to such a points
that just three years after independence
in 1963
violence broke out the situation led
Turkey to threaten military intervention
in order to protect Turkish Cypriots
finally the United States managed to
defuse the situation but the battle had
just begun after years of intermittent
instability and tense calm finally in
1974 a controlled coup d'etat from
Athens overthrew Archbishop Makarios the
Third's government and triggered just
five days later Turkey's invasion of
Northern Cyprus and so that's how a
division was drawn which continues to
this day and which was formally
recognized in 1983 with the unilateral
creation of the state of the Turkish
Republic of Northern Cyprus a country of
just three hundred thousand inhabitants
which is only recognized by Turkey and
that 36 years after its independence
doesn't even have a national anthem
[Music]
it also explains why in the capital city
of this island Nicosia we can find a
Berlin style wall that divides the city
into but would you like to know how
Cyprus handles this national division
today and what remains of the past
tensions what would we find if we went
in Nicosia Cyprus is capital right now
nicosia Europe's last divided capital
walking through some areas of Nicosia
today is the closest thing to walking
through old divided Berlin
[Music]
in many streets especially those of the
old walled city you can see barriers
fences and walls made with barrels
filled with concrete
[Music]
it's the separation between the Greek
Cypriots and Turkish Cypriot Nicosia a
separation that has a completely
abandoned demilitarized strip that is
controlled by the UN known as the Green
Line
[Music]
this line extends from end to end across
the island and is a korean-style
demilitarized zone with a maximum width
of seven kilometers and which accounts
for 3% of the entire islands territory
but it's in the capital Nicosia where
the Green Line is most apparent it is
there that the worst clashes between
both communities took place during the
second half of the 20th century
give you an idea in the capital time
seems to have stopped along the strip
and as a testament of that convulsive
past you can see for example of the
former airport
[Music]
it's a facility that was completely
abandoned in 1974 yes since the coup and
subsequent Turkish invasion
[Music]
now the only function of this airport is
to serve as a backdrop when a few
tourists decide to pose for pictures in
the old waiting rooms and in front of
the corroded 60 star check-in desks
which seemed to have been left over from
an apocalyptic movie of course for those
who love dark tourism it's a must-see
and that's not all in the old workshops
in car dealerships of the Green Line in
Nicosia you can see old imported and
abandoned models that nobody has touched
since 1974 there are also bars
restaurants and abandoned houses where
you can still see old bottles of
coca-cola on the table and gunshot
blasts on the facades but we aren't just
talking about an abandoned strip of land
even though the tensions have remained
dormant in recent years the issue goes
much deeper
allow me to explain despite being in the
Mediterranean the Turkish Republic of
Northern Cyprus is one of the most
isolated places on earth
it hasn't been recognized by any
countries and has been internationally
sanctioned for the past four decades
from an international point of view it's
only access is Turkey its inhabitants
lack their own passport and any
establishments with international brands
and franchises is prohibited at all
levels economically socially and
politically it's as if we didn't exist
we live in a country where regular
contact with the rest of the world is
severely compromised ah still nah me
special Turkish Cypriot representative
to the negotiations for resolving the
Cyprus dispute in fact it wasn't until
2003 when some restrictions were
relieved that the green line was crossed
for the first time in more than 30 years
now at this point the question that
crops up is what can be done to resolve
this could this division and soon
[Music]
well if you look at the history it seems
hard even with the help of the Secretary
General of the United Nations who is
determined to achieve reunification
[Music]
Antonia Gutierrez has set himself the
challenge of achieving an agreement to
reunify Cyprus under a bi-communal and
bi-zonal federal system and to do so
2020 could either be a turning point or
just another year on the already long
list of Cyprus's diplomatic failures for
now the UN has set itself the objective
of resuming negotiations in mid 2020 un
hell's frank cyprus talks vows to seek
peace effort restart al jazeera however
in recent years a new player has emerged
further complicating the issue
[Music]
reunification an impossible road when
anything breaks putting back together is
very complicated and of course if we're
talking about countries it can be an
almost impossible mission that's exactly
what's happening in Cyprus you see even
though the tensions between both
communities have greatly decreased there
are still difficult barriers to overcome
what will happen to the Turkish troops
considering that Turkish Cypriots
basically depend on them how will the
issue if the properties seized from
Greek Cypriot owners be resolved how
will both communities be politically
organized so that one isn't under the
other's control how will the territory
be distributed what will happen with
social policy will the south finance the
development of services and
infrastructure in the much poorer north
with all these questions guns are now a
geostrategic problem one that threatens
to kill these negotiations and which has
a lot to do with something we've already
talked about here on this channel
Cyprus is currently involved as a
commercial and economic turning point
that turkey doesn't approve of and even
though the Turkish Republic of Northern
Cyprus is in theory an independent
country the truth is that Turkey rules
Northern Cyprus interests by aligning
them with theirs especially when it
comes to international politics after
all it's the only country that
recognizes this Republic while also
maintaining more than 30 thousand
soldiers deployed on the islands the
fact is that it's here that we face a
new obstacle in the shape of a long
thick tube located under the sea we're
talking about the East Med gas pipeline
the East med is a pipeline whose
construction could begin very soon which
will allow Israel to export natural gas
directly to Europe by 2025 Israel and
Cyprus which has also began to exploit
its gas reserves at sea
and as we've already discussed in a
previous video
Israel has managed to boost its gas
production achieving a very significant
production figures in fact just a short
time ago on January the second 2020 it
took a giant step regarding this project
leaders from Israel Cyprus Greece sine
East med gas-pipe deal Bloomberg now the
question is why could this be a problem
when it comes to conversations about
Cypriot reunification well because this
clash is directly with the geostrategic
and economic interests of Turkey which
is where the gas pipeline that currently
takes its ported gas from the Middle
East to Europe flows this situation
gives Turkey the power to control the
passage of a vital supply to a continent
that hasn't been very friendly to the
Turkish regime in recent years you can
imagine how this goes right well if we
add to this mix the facts that it's
Israel who would benefit the most from
this project then things get even more
complicated because lately Turkey and
Israel at getting on worse than Batman
and Joker
so if reunification was already a
challenge this new confrontation between
Turkey and the Republic of Cyprus only
looks to make it much more complicated
anyway this is how things stand in
Cyprus today but now it's your turn did
you know about the Turkish Republic of
Northern Cyprus do you think these two
states should reunify or should they
maintain their independence well leave
your answer in the comments below and I
really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also please do check
out our friends at the reconsider Media
podcast you provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine also this
channel is possible because of patreon
ins our patrons on that platform please
join them in supporting our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see in the next video
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at reconsider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast see you there
[Music]